the European Parliament price for cinema
looks price is a voltage two of their
under inciter from patty a keen
diposkan al lado Steph inoue a Kasim at
no see beyond assume le soir c'est
calmly plant andhra el le puso la
lumière una besoin de SasuSaku comf
arancini marquis were commercial filming
in Turkey gives us a bit of insight we
know how difficult it is for Turkey to
become a member or for the rest of
Europe having Turkey as a new member but
we see if we film in in Turkey in
Istanbul we see a great self confidence
of the Turkish people and we think it
will be quite a process for Turkish
society to be to become a member but we
think it's the only way to go